you are already planning you take
Halloween very serious so young yeah I'm
just curious because I I kicked the
Halloween habit when I was like eight no
I just was like oh this is nonsense
enough for that
no and I let it go but you're you're
hanging on oh yeah I'm hanging on to
what my son is nine and we're in New
York we live in New York and he loves
Halloween and I love Halloween and so I
started to decorate kind of so he would
be entertained and it went from just
sort of dressing up and greeting kids at
the door to now I line both sides of the
hallway we have kind of an entrance
hallway with black curtains all the way
down this is about a 35 foot hallway and
I put a fog machine at the very end yes
I run the fog machine and I've got a
cauldron with bubbling stuff inside and
the kids they come halfway down the
hallway and they look because I leave
the door open and they look in and I
also have a soundtrack going of screams
and it's New York so no one does
anything he probably just left a window
open anyway the kids get scared and they
come halfway down we have to coax them
in just to get the candy out of work to
get candy in my building guys who just
greets them in a well-lit hallway and
says you know here's your candy and take
as much as you want
no you must enter in a whole new reality
because is this an apartment building
yes I can't believe you're puffing smoke
I know I know sometimes it gets a little
out of hand but yeah it just creates a
good atmosphere all right sure all right
yeah what could go wrong sure and you
also you like to make your own costumes
yeah yes that's cool I respect that yeah
I kind of last-minute it's better
last-minute there's a desperation to it
that I think is important
what did you what did you make recently
that you could just give us a flavor of
what you I'll a steer I was a vegetable
about which vegetable a leafy vegetable
okay I went as kale uh-huh
went as K what is kale yeah so I got the
hot glue gun out and you know kale is a
waxy vegetable and hot glue and kale it
doesn't really work because the kale
just slips right off which I learned
later that evening as I went out and
left a trail of kale way to the party
which that's how I found my way home in
fact all been eaten by vegan hipsters
[Laughter]
[Applause]
give me almond milk with this it's got
hot blue on it yeah yeah so you were
shedding kale as you went through the
night yeah I think we have a picture of
you as kale how much have you lost at
that point oh I've lost a fair amount
you see me holding on kind of squeezing
you're trying to just hang on to the
kale first yeah and you know it's a
smelly vegetable so as the evening went
along if you only planned this out very
well did I know and then did you know
we'd be showing it on this show
you